Prof: I think I'm going
to start.
So this is really the beginning
of the finance part of the
course.
So far we've reviewed general
equilibrium, which I said Fisher
invented or reinvented in order
to do finance.
And as you remember the main
conclusions from general
equilibrium are first that the
market functioning by itself
without interference from the
outside,
in other words a situation of
laissez-faire,
leads to allocations that are
Pareto efficient.
So they're in some sense good
for the economy and good for the
society.
They don't maximize total
welfare.
That's not even a well-defined
thing as we saw last time
because how can you measure,
how can you add one person's
utility to another.
It doesn't even make sense.
So economists at first were
wrong to think of that as the
criterion for good allocations,
but there's another better
definition of efficiency that
Pareto invented,
called Pareto Efficiency,
and the free market achieves
Pareto Efficiency at least if
there are no externalities and
there's no monopoly.
So that, lesson number one,
was taken to mean that the
government shouldn't interfere
in the free market,
especially shouldn't interfere
in financial markets,
and that's something we're
going to come to examine.
The second lesson we found was
that the price is determined by
marginal utility.
It's not determined by total
utility.
So it may be that water is much
more valuable than diamonds
because it does a lot more good
for everybody and for the world
as a whole than diamonds do,
but the last drop of water,
really most people have as much
water as they need,
the last drop of water is not
doing that much whereas the last
diamond is a rare thing and not
many people have them.
So the last drop of water is
worth less than the last equal
weight of diamonds and therefore
water is much cheaper than
diamonds even though water's
much more valuable as a whole
than diamonds.
The price of things depends on
their marginal utility.
A third implication of what we
did is that there's no such
thing as a just price.
It depends on what peoples'
utilities are and how much they
like it.
It depends on how much of the
good there is.
That's why diamonds are priced
less than water [correction:
that's why water is priced less
than diamonds].
And it depends on how wealthy
people are.
If you transfer money from
people who don't like apples
compared to tomatoes,
to people who like apples a lot
the price in the free market is
going to reflect more the latter
class of people than the former
because they've got the money to
spend,
and so the price of apples is
going to go up relative to the
price of tomatoes.
So those are the three basic
lessons of general equilibrium.
The first one about
laissez-faire has a huge
implication for whether there
should be regulation,
but the second pair of
implications,
what determines the price and
how price changes as you
redistribute wealth and so on,
and no just price,
that set of ideas,
you'll see, is also going to be
very important for finance.
So those lessons seem clear.
Some of those lessons were
understood already by Aristotle
as we said.
So the ancients understood
supply and demand,
at least a little bit of supply
and demand,
and yet as soon as they moved
from apples and oranges to
finance,
they all got hopelessly
confused.
So Aristotle said,
"Interest is
unnatural."
I could go through a lot of
people and what they said,
but I'm going to just leave it
at a few quotations.
The Bible says interest is
terrible.
Judaism frowns on interest.
Christianity frowns on interest.
Islam frowns on interest.
All the great religions of the
world crystallizing,
obviously, some of the most
important thinking of the time,
frowns on interest,
so just to remind you of a few.
So why do they frown on
interest?
Well, the idea is that you do
nothing, the lender does nothing
and he gets back more than he
lent to begin with.
He's making a profit without
having exerted any effort
whatsoever.
So, Sulinay Middleton said,
"In trade both parties are
expected to gain,
whereas in lending at usury
only the usurer could
profit."
So in Deuteronomy in the Bible,
so this is the Jewish Bible,
is says, "Thou shalt not
lend on usury,"
(that just means interest).
"Thou shalt not lend on
usury to thy brother.
Usury of money,
usury of victuals,
usury of anything that is lent
upon usury, "--that's all
terrible.
Of course, "unto a
foreigner thou mayest lend upon
usury, but unto a brother thou
shalt not lend upon usury."
So the Jews could lend to
Christians but not to each
other.
So the Christian Church
outlawed usury,
called it a mortal sin.
Luther, for example,
says, "For who so lends
that he wants it back better or
more, that is open and damnable
ocker.
Those who do that are all
daylight robbers,
thieves and ockerers.
Those are little Jewish arts
and tricks."
So there was this antipathy
towards usury,
and because Jewish moneylenders
were able to lend to Christians
there was an antipathy to Jewish
moneylenders which we're going
to come to when we talk about
Shakespeare.
So Muslims also forbid lending.
In fact, even today it's
illegal to charge interest in
Islamic law.
So in my hedge fund we tried to
raise money,
and there's lots of money in
the Middle East,
and most of it,
by the way, ten years ago,
almost all Middle Eastern money
was invested in U.S.
Government bonds and U.S.
stocks, nothing else like in
mortgages, for instance.
So I went to Saudi Arabia and I
met a bunch of brothers of the
King, the eldest brothers of the
King, and I suggested they
invest in our hedge fund.
And they actually became sort
of interested,
and so we had to write up a
complicated contract.
Now, you know a mortgage pays
interest,
so if you invest in the hedge
fund and the mortgage is paying
interest it looks like they're
getting interest,
and so that wasn't going to do.
So we had to write a very
elaborate contract which
disguised the fact that interest
was being paid,
and it had to be overseen and
blessed according to Sharia Law
by a holy person who was going
to verify that there was no
interest.
Now he charged a fee which was
a percent a year which looked an
awful lot like interest,
but anyway so.
So the point is all these
religions have banished interest
despite the fact that they
themselves were involved in
interest,
and lending, and borrowing.
A world can't function really
without lending and borrowing
and the charging of interest.
So these religions that forbade
it at the same time knew that it
was going on and allowed it to
go on and sometimes participated
in it.
But the point I'm trying to
make is that there was vast
confusion,
and even today there's
confusion because still today
the Jewish law doesn't allow for
interest between Jews,
and--there's a charade that
goes on there just like there is
in Islamic law,
and just like there is--still
frowned upon by the Christian
Church.
So it's a hard subject to
understand, and why is that?
Why is it that it's so
confusing, and how should we
understand it?
Well, Fisher cut through all
this extremely simply,
and the way he did it was he
said, "Let's just think
mathematically then we won't get
so tied up in all these
religious complexities.
Just let's do something
mathematical and concrete."
So suppose that we consider a
problem, which is the one I'm
going to work with the rest of
the class.
Maybe I better do it over here.
So let's say that there are two
agents and two goods.
So the two goods now are
X_1 and X_2.
So Fisher's first insight is
that let's think of
X_1 and X_2
as apples,
but apples today and apples
next year,
Fisher said--although they're
both apples,
exactly alike,
there's no difference between
these apples,
the apples this year are
different goods from the apples
next year.
So let's move away from apples
and tomatoes to apples this year
and apples next year.
So I'm not going to call them
goods X and Y anymore.
I'm going to subscript them by
time.
These are both X because it's
the same good,
but they're different goods
because they occur at different
time periods.
So Fisher said we can
incorporate time simply by
having different goods.
So of course people,
he said, are going to have some
utility of consuming today
versus consuming tomorrow,
and let's say this utility is
(log X_1) (1 half log
X_2) for Mr. A.
So I'm going to come back to
this in half an hour and explain
why Fisher thought that this
half made sense.
You see, this Agent A likes
good 1 a lot more than good 2.
So Fisher would say that's
because Agent A is inpatient.
An apple is an apple,
but if you get it now it's
worth more to you,
it gives you higher utility
than getting an apple next year.
"This is a law of human
nature,"
he claimed,
which I'm going to come back to
later,
and that's why when you write
down the utility function
there's a discount factor,
which we're going to add--a
discount factor--
which discounts,
reduces, the utility you get
from future consumption.
So let's say (U^(B) of
X_1 and X_2)
= (log X_1 log
X_2).
So B is more patient than A is.
B actually doesn't discount the
future.
A does discount the future.
So A is impatient,
relatively impatient,
and B is patient.
They have endowments,
so E^(A) let's say the
endowment is (1,0).
Say it is (1,1) and E^(B) let's
make that (1,0).
But now Fisher wants to talk
about finance and he wants to
talk about stocks,
and bonds, and interest and all
kinds of things.
So he says, "We've talked
about good with no problem.
We can talk about goods today
and next year with no problem,
let's talk about stocks."
What is a stock?
Let's say there are two stocks,
stock alpha and stock beta.
What are stocks?
I mean, they're pieces of paper
that you're trading,
but they give you ownership of
something like a factory or a
company or something,
and what good is the company?
Well the good of the company is
that it's going to produce
something.
So let's say that the stock is
going to produce something in
the future.
So we'll call the production of
the stock--so what is the
future?
There are only apples in the
future.
So let's say
D^(alpha)_2 is 1 and
D^(beta)_2 = 2.
Fisher says,
you can tell a lot of stories
about what this stock does,
and what its method of
production is,
and what kind of managers it
has and a lot of stuff like
that,
but in the end people care
about the stock because the
stock is going to produce
something,
and the value of the stock is
going to come from what it
produces.
So D^(alpha)_2 is
what people expect the output of
the stock to be next year which
is the last year we're worrying
about,
and D^(beta)_2 which
is 2 is what people expect the
stock to produce next year.
And we're going to assume that
perfect foresight here.
So Fisher says, "Well,
in general people's
expectations might be
wrong," but let's start off
with the case--
people anticipate something,
surely they're looking ahead to
the future when deciding whether
to buy the stock.
We've got to assume something
about what they think.
Let's suppose they actually get
it right and they know what the
price of the stock is next
period.
So what's going to happen?
Well, we can define an economy
and presumably the interest rate
and the stock prices and all
that are going to come out.
Now I should mention,
by the way, I forgot to say
this, but as I write this down I
suddenly realize I forgot to
mention it.
There are other theories of
interest too.
Another famous one was Marx's
Theory of Interest.
So this is to be contrasted
with Fisher.
What did Marx say?
So in my youth when I was your
age it was very fashionable to
be a Marxist.
You had to study Marxism
basically.
If you wanted to talk to women
you had to know about Marx.
So anyhow, I dutifully went off
and read Marx.
And so what's the idea of Marx?
The idea was that he imagined
an agricultural economy where
you plant stuff today and then
the output comes out tomorrow.
So you put corn in today,
corn comes out tomorrow.
So it doesn't require much
effort to plant the corn.
You have to buy the corn.
So the capitalists would buy
the corn, but planting it didn't
require much effort.
However, harvesting it,
picking the cotton,
picking the chocolate,
picking all that stuff takes a
lot of effort.
So in the end you'd get a lot
of output.
Now when you pick the output
you'd have to pay workers in
order to pick the output.
So Marx imagined that there was
a wage that was arrived at by
the struggle,
class struggle,
between the capitalists and the
workers over the subsistence
wage.
So the subsistence wage was
something that resulted from
this huge class struggle,
and over time maybe it would
rise as workers got stronger,
but it was still always quite
low and the subsistence wage was
what the workers would get.
And what's left over,
which was the surplus--so the
output being more than what was
put in, was the surplus.
Part of the surplus would go to
the subsistence wage.
The rest would go to profit.
And so if you look at how much
was put in to begin with,
you get all the output back
out, the same amount of corn you
put in plus some extra you have
to give to the workers,
and extra that the capitalist
gets back as his profit.
The fact that the capitalist
has done no work at all,
he's just bought the corn,
let someone else plant it,
let someone else harvest,
paid all those guys virtually
nothing at the beginning and a
lot at the end,
he's gotten profit for doing
nothing just like when you lend
money,
so the profit divided by the
initial outlay,
that was the rate of interest.
And so Marx said that a
capitalist, he could put his
money in his bank or he could
run this farm and make profit
this way.
So the money,
interest in the bank would have
to turn out to be the same as
this rate of profit otherwise
he'd put all the money in the
bank.
And if it was smaller the banks
would have to give higher
interest in order to attract
depositors.
So the capitalist's
profit--rate of interest was
determined by the rate of profit
and the rate of profit was
determined by the struggle
between capital and labor.
So we've got these religious
figures and great philosophers
saying interest is terrible.
We've got this great
philosopher-economist saying
it's the result of a class
struggle,
and now we've got Fisher,
actually Marx was pretty
mathematical,
but now we've got Fisher
turning it into a simple math
problem and saying,
"Let's reason out the math
problem and we'll have the
answer to these questions,
and it'll turn out to be quite
different from what all these
guys are saying."
So here's his economy that I
just described.
The Fisher example,
not literally an example he
gave, but similar to one he
gave.
So he said, "All right,
what happens in this economy?
Let's just be very
commonsensical.
What we need to find out now is
financial equilibrium,"
so financial equilibrium is
much more complicated seeming
than we had before,
because we care about the
prices.
So now I'm going to use (q) for
prices, a q for contemporary
prices,
q_contemporary,
so the price you pay today to
get the apple today.
q_2 is the price you
pay next year to get the apple
next year.
They're contemporary prices.
And of course people are going
to decide what they want to do,
X^(A)_1,
what they're going to end up
consuming X^(A)_2,
X^(B)_1,
X^(B)_2,
but now we've got a more
complicated world.
There's stocks to be traded and
there's the price of stocks.
So P--pi_alpha,
I'm running out of letters.
I'm going to switch to a Greek
one.
This is the price of stock A,
stock alpha.
And pi_beta is the
price of stock beta.
And then we have to know how
many shares are they going to
hold?
Well, it's going be theta^(A),
A's going to hold a certain
number of shares of alpha,
and theta^(A)_beta,
A's going to hold a certain
number of shares of stock beta,
and B's going to hold a certain
number of shares of alpha and a
certain number of shares of
beta.
So we want to solve for all of
that.
Now, I should have said at the
beginning if these are trees
producing apples there was an
initial stock.
People owned a certain number
of trees.
So let's say
theta-bar_alpha^(A),
so this is the original
ownership of alpha.
Let's just say that's,
I'll make up some number.
I might as well use the same
number I thought of before.
Let's say that's 1,
and let's say
theta-bar^(B)_alpha is
0,
and let's say theta-bar^(A) of
beta is a half,
and theta-bar^(B) of beta is a
half.
So the original economy is more
complicated than before because
we've added stocks.
We characterized the stock.
We said a stock is a very
complicated thing.
A company is very complicated,
depends on managers and
processes and there's all kinds
of stuff you think about when
you think about a stock,
but really at heart all people
are trying to do is forecast
what are they going to produce.
And so we're going to make it
simple mathematically and say
let's say we know what they're
going to produce next period.
So let's say it's a tree.
Everybody knows the alpha
tree's producing 1 apple.
The beta tree's producing two
apples.
Alpha happens to own the only
alpha tree.
A owns the alpha tree,
excuse me, and A and B own half
each of the beta tree.
So that's the original economy
and the equilibrium is going to
be,
what are the prices going to
turn out to be of X_1
and X_2,
what are the prices of the
trees going to turn out to be,
how much will people consume
and how many shares?
Because alpha A began with all
of tree maybe he'll sell his
shares of tree and end up with
not having a tree in the end.
So we have to see where they
began, the stock ownership to
begin with and where they end
up.
So we have to solve all of that
and it looks way more
complicated than before,
and so complicated that you can
see why people might have gotten
confused.
But according to Fisher it's
going to turn out to be a very
simple problem in the end once
we look at it the right way.
So are there any questions
about what the economy is and
what are the variables that
we're trying to explain?
Yeah?
Student: Sorry,
I can't read what that says
over theta alpha A.
That's original ownership?
Prof: Original ownership
of stock alpha.
And this is original ownership
by B of stock alpha.
This original ownership by A of
stock beta, and this is the
original ownership by B of stock
beta, original ownership of
alpha.
Thanks.
Yes?
Student: Having defined
all of these could you redefine
what D stands for?
Prof: D is the dividend.
That's the output that we can
all--thank you.
I should just write this down.
This is the anticipated
dividend, which is the output
since that's the end of the
world of stock alpha in period
2.
And D^(beta) of 2 is the
anticipated dividend of stock
beta in period 2.
So it's 1 apple we're getting
out of the alpha tree,
2 apples out of the beta tree,
right?
That's what the tree's good for.
We can look at how beautiful it
is.
We could talk about how much
the owner's actually watering
the tree.
We can talk about a lot of
complicated stuff,
but in the end all we care
about is how many apples we
expect to get out of it.
All the other stuff goes into
helping us think about how many
apples we're going to get out of
it in the end.
So we cut to the bottom line.
What are the apples we expect
to get out of tree,
1 from the alpha tree,
2 from the beta tree.
Someone else had their hand up.
Student: I had it,
but you answered it.
Prof: Any other
questions about this set up?
So we're returning to first
principles here,
very simple example.
When there's ever a big
confusion about something
important it's always good to go
to first principles.
There was a chess player when I
was young named Mikhail Tal who
was a world champion for a
little while,
and he said that every two or
three years he'd go back and
read his original introductory
textbooks on chess.
So we're going back to the
first principles.
How would you define
equilibrium here for a financial
equilibrium?
Well, the first thing is just
common sense.
What are people doing?
At time 1 what can they do?
They can spend money,
so I'm going to look at the
budget set for Agent i,
and i can be A or B so I don't
have to write it twice.
So he's going to say to
himself, let's say A is he and B
is she, i is he.
He's going to say to
himself--let's say i will say,
"How much does it cost me
to buy goods?"
Well, the cost of apples is
q_1 times
X_1.
That's how many apples I might
end up with.
Now, how much does it cost me
to buy shares?
It's going to be
pi_alpha times how
many shares I end up with,
theta_alpha,
plus (pi_beta times
theta_beta).
So I'm buying goods,
I'm buying alpha shares and I'm
buying beta shares and this is
how much I have to spend to get
the holdings I want of each.
Now where did I get the money
to do that?
I got the money to do that
because I started with my
endowment of goods which was
E^(i)_1,
which in this case for A was 1
unit,
for B was also 1 unit,
and then I also had shares to
begin with of these stocks.
So I had ([pi_alpha
times]
theta-bar_alpha)
(pi_beta
theta-bar_beta).
In period 1 that's what I had
to do.
I wanted to buy apples,
shares and I had shares to sell
and apples to sell.
So that's what i did.
So of course if X_1
is bigger than the number of
apples i started with that means
i has bought apples because he
ends up with more than he
started with,
so that meant he must have been
buying apples.
If theta_alpha is
more than
theta-bar_alpha it
means that alpha [correction:
i]
bought shares of stock alpha.
Theta_alpha is less
than theta-bar_alpha
it means alpha [correction:
i]
sold shares of stock alpha.
All right, now in the second
period what happens?
Well, in the second period we
have q_2 times
X_2.
The shares are going to be
worthless in period 2.
So no one's going to buy them.
Why are the shares worthless?
Remember that when you buy a
share of stock the dividend
comes later.
You don't get the dividend
immediately.
So someone buying stock in
period 2, it's too late to get
the dividend.
It's already gone to the owner
who bought the shares in period
1.
So the buyer of a stock
[doesn't]
gets the dividend for a month
or something.
So next period's dividend is
still going to go to the buyer
in period 1,
that's why it's valuable to buy
shares in period 1 because you
get next year's apple.
So by next period you can buy
the tree, but the world's coming
to end.
That tree's not going to do you
any good.
It doesn't produce any more
apples.
So nobody's going to bother
buying shares.
I don't have to bother with
them.
The prices are zero.
And so what income do people
have in period 2?
Well, they've got the
contemporaneous price times the
apples that somehow they find on
the ground or that their parents
are going to leave them when
they get old.
So that's their endowment of
apples, but what else do they
have?
They've got more apples than
that.
What else do they have?
Student: The dividends.
Prof: The dividends.
So what are the dividends?
Well, you bought
theta_alpha to begin
with so that's
D^(alpha)_2.
So if you bought the whole tree
then you've got all the
dividends, and similarly with
beta.
Theta_beta times
D^(beta)_2
[correction:
theta_beta times
D^(beta)_2 times
q_2.
And, theta_alpha
times D^(alpha)_2
should also be multiplied by
q_2].
So that's it.
So the budget set is a little
more complicated.
So that's the budget set.
So it's got 2 equalities
instead of 1 equality,
so already things look a little
more complicated.
Now, so an equilibrium is going
to have to be that i chooses
(X^(i)_1,
X^(i)_2),
theta_alpha--
I can write,
theta^(i)_alpha,
theta^(i)_beta,
that's all the choices he has
to maximize U^(i) subject to
this budget set.
So A's going to pick what
shares to hold,
how much to consume today,
then, of course,
looking forward A's going to be
able to figure out what he's
going to end up consuming
tomorrow.
All right so,
and now in equilibrium we have
to have that (X^(A)_1
X^(B)_1) has to =
(E^(A)_1
E^(B)_1).
And then we do the shares,
theta^(A)_alpha
theta^(B)_alpha has to
= theta-bar^(A)_alpha
theta-bar^(B)_alpha,
right?
The stock market has to clear
and theta^(A)_beta
theta^(B)_beta has to
= theta-bar^(A)_beta
theta-bar^(B)_beta.
So in period 1 the demand for
apples has to equal the supply
of all the agents,
but now what's the last
equation?
This is a little trickier.
What's the last equation?
X^(A)_2
X^(B)_2 =
E^(A)_2
E^(B)_2 ....
Is that it?
No.
There's something else.
Student: Plus dividends.
Prof: The total
consumption of apples is going
to be the apples that they have
on the ground,
but also the ones that were
picked off the trees,
so these dividends.
So it's going to be the total
dividends which are
[(theta-bar^(A)_alpha
theta-bar^(B)_alpha)
times that tree--
D^(alpha)_2]
[(theta-bar^(A)_beta
theta-bar^(B)_beta)
times D^(beta)_2].
So just to say it in words,
it's exactly what we had before
except we have to take into
account in addition to the goods
market clearing,
we have to take into account
that the stock market has to
clear.
And in the end demand for goods
has to equal the supply that
people had in their endowments,
but also what the companies are
producing.
These companies are producing
output, apples.
And so that's part of what the
consumption is going to be in
the economy.
Are you with me here?
It's a good time for questions,
maybe.
Yes?
Student: Could you just
explain again why we don't take
stocks into consideration in
period 2?
Prof: So in period 2 you
might wonder,
pi_alpha is the price
of the stock at period 1,
stock alpha in period 1.
Pi_beta's the price
of the stock beta in period 1.
How come I didn't write down
the price of the stocks in
period 2 and keep track of what
they're holding in period 2?
And the reason is that when you
buy a stock you're buying it not
for the dividends at this same
moment in time.
You don't get those dividends.
The guy who already had it gets
those dividends.
When you buy the stock you're
buying it for the future
dividends you can get,
and I've assumed the world's
going to end after 2 periods
because nobody's utility cares
about period 3.
So if you buy the stock in
period 2 it's too late for you
to get anything.
There are no dividends because
you can only get them in period
3,
and there won't be any
dividends in period 3,
and if there were you wouldn't
care about them anyway.
So the stock's worthless to you.
So the price of the stock in
period 2, of both stocks,
is going to be 0.
So there's no point in putting
down what people are buying of
the stocks or selling or
anything.
It's just not worth anything.
But in general you're right,
and we're going to be more
complicated later when you look
at your income from having
bought the stocks.
You'll have as your income the
dividend from the stocks plus
the resale value of the stock,
because you could sell the
stock next period.
But I just know the resale
value's going to be zero because
you're in the last period of the
economy.
And I just want to keep it very
simple this first time.
Step by step you'll be able to
keep very complicated things in
your head but not right at
first, so any other questions?
Yes?
Student: Why are there
endowments in period 1 and
>?
Prof: You mean why do
people have endowments today and
next year?
Because you could think of the
endowment,
for example,
as--here we've got apples,
but usually the endowment is
your labor,
so you can work this year--your
most important endowment is your
energy and your labor.
So you've got it this year.
Next year if you're still alive
that's new labor that you have.
It's a different good so it's a
second endowment that you have.
So I don't want to get caught
up in labor and all that and get
involved with Marx again,
so I'm just going to talk about
apples.
You have an endowment of apples
when you're young and next year
somehow you're going to have
more apples.
So you might have thought that
the only apples next year come
from what the firms are
producing,
but I allowed for the
possibility that people have
apples too just like their labor
next year.
Other questions?
Yeah?
Student: We then have to
define E_2^(A) and
E_2^(B) in terms of
first period endowments,
or is that something implied in
the equation?
Prof: I should have
written this more carefully
maybe.
E^(A)_1 and
E^(A)_2 is that,
and this is E^(B)_1
and E^(B)_2 is that.
So as he was suggesting back
there I've assumed for person B
that he's got an apple now.
We aren't modeling what
happened to get us here.
The guys got an apple today.
They both have an apple today.
Somehow A's also going to have
another apple tomorrow that he's
going to find under his doorstep
somehow that isn't being
produced by the tree.
And maybe you can think of it
as labor that he's going to have
next period.
All right, so that's it.
Fisher says as soon as you
write down the economy
mathematically all sorts of
things are going to occur to you
which if you're talking in words
about justice and injustice
you're going to be lost.
So what can we get right away
out of this?
What can we get right away out
of this?
Well, the first thing is,
how would we define inflation?
What is inflation?
What's inflation in this
economy?
Assuming we've got the
equilibrium,
which we're going to get soon,
we're going to calculate it,
but right now we don't what the
numbers--
you know we've got a bunch of
equations and stuff.
We don't know what
X^(A)_1 and
q_1 and q_2
are going to turn out to be,
but we're going to find out
very soon.
But before we find out,
assuming we've gotten those,
what will inflation be?
What is inflation?
Yeah?
Student: Is it how much
the ratio of the price of the
dividend has changed?
Prof: Well,
we're talking about inflation.
When you talk about the
Consumer Price Index,
inflation, what are they
talking about?
Yeah?
Student: It's the rise
of q_1 and
q_2.
Prof: So inflation is
just q_2 over
q_1,
right?
So that's the price of apples
today.
That's the price of apples next
year.
If the price of apples next
year is bigger than this year
we've got inflation.
If it's lower we've got
deflation.
So already the model,
you're talking about inflation.
What else?
What's the next most obvious?
Well, I think I'm going to skip
a bunch of stuff and get now to
the key idea.
The key idea is arbitrage.
So Fisher says,
"People have
foresight."
They're anticipating what the
dividends are going to be.
They understand that you can
talk about how beautiful the
tree is,
and how much you like the
owners, and how much they're
watering it,
and whether they have a good
plan for irrigation,
and whether they did well in
college and stuff like that,
but in the end all you care
about the trees is how many
apples they're going to produce.
So knowing that,
can we say something about
pi_alpha pi alpha
versus pi_beta?
In equilibrium what's going to
have to happen?
There is going to be some
connection, and what's the
connection going to be?
You've got two trees.
Yeah?
Student: The ratio
between the prices would be the
ratio between the
>?
Prof: Right,
so pi_alpha is going
to be pi_beta times
D[^(alpha)_2 over
D^(beta)_2]--
alpha will be better as long as
the--
hopefully I've got that in the
right order.
And so in this case
pi_alpha is going to
equal a half pi_beta,
because alpha's producing half
the dividend that beta's
producing.
So obviously it's going to turn
out to have half the price.
That's the fundamental
principle.
We're doing it in the most
trivial case,
but it's the most fundamental
principle of finance that if
you've got two assets and
they're basically the same up to
scale then their prices have to
be the same up to scale.
Who's going to bother to buy
alpha if it costs the same
amount as beta when it only
produces half as much?
Yes?
Student: Is that the
same thing as saying that their
yields will converge,
that equation?
Prof: Well,
it is something like that,
but that's a word that we
haven't defined yet,
so we're going to define it in
the next class.
So it's something like that,
yep.
Any other?
So that is a very simple thing.
Suppose after finding the
equilibrium I added a third
asset that paid 1 dollar in
period 2 next year.
Now, it would have a price
of--added a third asset gamma,
so pi_gamma--we'd
have to solve for the
equilibrium pi_gamma,
and is there some word that I
could use?
So gamma is an asset that pays
a dollar in period 2.
It's like a bond promising a
dollar in period two.
The price of the bond would
then have to be what?
1 over (1 i) where i is called
the nominal interest rate,
so we've got inflation is
occurring in the model.
If I added a bond,
which I didn't bother to do
because it's just yet another
thing I'd have to write down,
I could have had a third asset
which pays a dollar.
The others are paying off in
apples.
This one's paying a dollar and
its price today,
if you pay 80 cents today it's
like saying I'm paying 80 cents
today,
I'm getting a whole dollar
tomorrow.
So it's like a 25 percent rate
of interest, because another way
of saying it is that 1 over
pi_gamma is 1 i.
I put only pi_gamma
in today,
I get 1 out tomorrow so I've
gotten back not only the
pi_gamma I put in but
something extra,
that's 1 the interest rate.
So this world is going to have
an interest rate in it.
It's going to have inflation in
it.
With me so far?
Let me add one more thing.
I could come back to this.
So I said that if you take
theta_alpha less than
theta-bar_alpha it
means you're selling the stock.
So I'm going to allow people to
go even further,
theta_alpha less than
0.
So let me just write that
again, theta_alpha
less than
theta-bar_alpha means
selling alpha.
Theta_alpha less than
0 is doing a lot more than
selling.
You don't have it to begin
with, so what are you selling?
Well, the mathematics is
telling you that over there
theta_alpha's going to
be negative.
Instead of getting extra
dividends you're going to be
giving up dividends because it's
going to reduce your supply of
money.
So theta_alpha less
than 0 is called selling short--
I don't know which one I've
lost, but it's got to be bad--
if you can still hear
me--you're selling short,
this means.
So you're selling something you
don't even have.
It's also called naked selling.
It's also called making a
promise without collateral.
So I'm going to,
for now, allow for that.
So we're not taking into
account that anybody's
defaulting.
If you take
theta_alpha negative
it means your income in the
future is going to be reduced
because you're going to have to
deliver the dividend because
you're going to have negative
dividends,
which means effectively you
take out of your endowment those
dividends and hand them over.
So it's as if you always keep
your promises.
So this model so far,
the Fisher model,
assumes no default,
no collateral.
We're not worrying about any of
that stuff, and of course that's
going to be a critical thing.
So you see something's happened
that we never had happen before.
In the past you traded money
for a football ticket.
You gave up something you
wanted you got something that
you also wanted.
It was a trade of value for
value.
Everybody agreed the two things
you traded were equally
valuable.
If you take
theta_alpha negative,
by taking theta_alpha
negative that becomes a negative
number here so it allows you to
spend more.
You can buy more goods by
taking theta_alpha
negative.
That's negative.
That means this can be more
positive and still satisfy this
constraint.
So by selling a stock short
you're promising to do something
in the future.
You get more money now you can
eat more now,
and then of course you have to
consume less in the future
because you have to pay back
your promise.
So you're exchanging something
valuable,
you're getting money,
something valuable in exchange
for a promise which is worth
nothing until the future when
you deliver on your promise.
When you buy the stock you're
buying part of the tree,
but the tree's doing nothing
for you now.
You're doing it because it's
going to be valuable next
period.
You're actually not physically
owning the tree,
you're owning a piece of paper
that gives you a right to half
the dividends of the tree.
So you're getting something
that's only good because it's a
promise you think is being kept.
So, so far for the next few
lectures we're going to ignore
the fact that people get very
nervous when they give something
up that's valuable in exchange
for something that's just a
promise.
So a critical thing has
happened here.
So we've kept the same
mathematics except we've
surreptitiously added this huge
assumption.
Now Fisher said,
"Having done that,
what can you realize?"
This is the most important
insight.
He said this model it looks so
complicated.
It looks like now we have
vastly more equations.
No wonder Marx and all those
religious zealots were getting
confused.
We can simplify it all and be
back to where we were before and
yet talk about finance.
So Fisher introduced the idea
of present value prices.
So he said look,
when you buy a stock what are
you really doing?
This is the principle of
arbitrage.
He says when you buy a stock
you're saying to yourself,
I'm giving up money today.
Now, money today is consumption
because I would have used that
money.
If I didn't buy stocks I would
have bought apples today and
eaten them.
So when I buy a stock I'm
giving up apples today.
I'm getting the stock which is
then paying me dividends
tomorrow,
which whatever they are I'm
selling off,
I'm getting a profit out of the
stock tomorrow and I'm ending up
with apples tomorrow.
Maybe I'm just eating the
dividends straight off the tree.
So when I buy a stock I'm
really giving up apples today
and getting apples tomorrow.
And no matter how I do it,
whether it's through stock
alpha,
or through stock beta,
or through a nominal bond it's
got to be the case that all
three ways,
or all 50 other ways you could
imagine doing it have to give me
the same tradeoff.
This is your yield you were
talking about,
the same tradeoff.
The amount of apples I
effectively give up today in
order to get apples tomorrow is
going to be the same no matter
which way I do it.
If it weren't the same,
if alpha's price was more than
a half of beta's nobody would
buy alpha.
In fact they would start
selling alpha.
So that's why this assumption
is so important.
What would they do?
Not only would nobody would buy
alpha, but they start selling
it.
They'd say well,
alpha is so expensive,
let's say it's the same price
as beta, I can sell alpha.
With every alpha I sell I can
buy stock beta,
and so I haven't done anything
today, but in the future I've
got stock beta which is paying
me 2.
I owe, because I sold stock
alpha short I owe 1,
so I'll pay off the 1 I owe and
I'll still be left with 1.
I'm making an arbitrage profit,
and so I'm not going to stop at
selling 1 share of alpha.
I'll sell 2 shares of alpha,
then 3 shares of alpha,
then a million shares of alpha,
and everybody'll be selling
alpha short to buy beta and the
market for alpha will never
clear.
So that's why the prices will
have to adjust.
And so it has to be in
equilibrium,
the price of alpha's exactly
half the price of beta,
which is to say,
in short, that if you solve for
this equilibrium you can solve
for an equilibrium where
P_1 = q_1 is
the price today of an apple
today,
and P_2 is the price
today (that's why it's called
present value price) of an apple
next year.
So if you've got this
equilibrium by working your way
through,
by figuring out what the price
of alpha is--
so the stock,
for example,
you want to figure out what the
stock is.
Suppose the stock of alpha,
suppose the price turns out to
be a half.
Then by paying a half today you
can buy stock alpha,
which is going to pay you a
whole dividend.
So the price,
therefore, of an entire--oh,
let's do beta.
Suppose the price of beta is a
quarter.
Suppose we happen to find out
that the price of beta is a
quarter.
Then what's P_2?
How much do you have to give up
today in order to get an apple?
Well, by paying a quarter
today, that's the price,
by paying a quarter today
you're getting 2 dividends.
So by paying a quarter today
If you paid to get 1 dividend
you'd have to pay an eighth
today.
So the price P_2
would be an eighth in that case.
So by piercing through the veil
of the stock market you can
always figure out what you're
effectively paying today in
order to get an apple next
period.
And that price which was just
computed would be the same
whether we looked at it from the
point of view of going through
stock beta,
or through stock alpha,
or through the nominal bond.
It would always have to give us
the same answer.
So we know, from the financial
equilibrium, we can deduce what
P_1 and P_2
have to be, the present value
prices.
And so effectively,
furthermore,
stocks effectively just add to
the endowments of goods.
So we can now consider another
economy.
So let's consider the economy
E-hat, so the hat economy.
So U-hat-^(A) of X_1
and X_2 is the same as
it was before,
U^(A) of X_1,
X_2,
U-hat^(B )of X_1 and
X_2 is the same as it
was before,
but endowments now
E-hat^(A)_1
E-hat^(A)_2 is going
to be what?
Well, A over here began with 1
unit of each good,
but A also owned all of stock
alpha and half of stock beta.
So all of stock alpha pays 1
dividend in the future,
so really A effectively has
claim on two apples in the
future and another half of beta
which is another apple in the
future,
so really A's initial endowment
of goods is (1,3).
How did I get that again?
I said it was 1 apple to begin
with he could anticipate having.
He knew he owned all of stock
alpha which pays 1 apple,
so that's another one that's
really his,
and then in the future he's
going to get half of the
dividends of stock beta,
and half of 2 is also 1.
So he's got 3 apples in the
future.
And E-hat^(B)2,
well his 1 doesn't change
today, but what's his claim,
effectively,
on dividends in the future?
Student: 1.
Prof: 1, thank you.
Somebody answered that.
So we've now reduced the
financial equilibrium to a
general equilibrium,
the same kind of economy we had
before.
It's just that we had to
augment the endowments to take
into account that people own
stuff through the stocks.
So what's the equilibrium of
this economy?
This has a simple general
equilibrium.
So what is it?
How do we solve for equilibrium?
Well, take P_1 = 1
and we'll solve for
P_2.
So let's just clear the first
market.
How do you clear it?
You're with me here?
It's a standard general
equilibrium, the same kind we've
done many times before.
So see if I can do it.
So person 1 is going to spend a
third of his money [correction:
will be two thirds],
and how much money does he
have?
He has (1 P_2 times
3), that's A,
right?
His endowment is (1,3).
This is his income,
and he's spending a third of it
on good 1.
And the price of good 1,
P_1,
here is just 1.
And then B is going to spend,
he's a half,
half Cobb-Douglas guy,
so this is 1 and this is 1.
He's spending half of his money
and his income is [1
P_2 times 1]
divided by 1,
and that has to equal the total
endowment which is 2,1 1.
So did I go too fast?
Yes?
Student: Why is it a
third?
Prof: Well,
it's probably wrong.
So let's try it again.
Maybe it's 2 thirds.
Let's see what I was doing.
I've taken the financial
economy, which was very
complicated,
looks very hard to solve and
Fisher says of course when we
add uncertainty and things like
that we're going to have to do
other tricks.
But without uncertainty,
with perfect foresight and so
on, and no uncertainty,
Fisher says this is an easy
problem to solve.
You take the financial
equilibrium with all its extra
variables and you realize if
people are rational they're
going to see through all that
complicated stuff.
They're going to realize that
alpha is just half as good as
beta,
and so they're going to realize
that by holding stock they're
making a certain tradeoff
between alpha and beta.
And we calculated the tradeoff.
What was P_2?
I forgot what P_2 was.
Anyway, how much did you have
to pay?
If you pay pi_alpha
divided by
D^(alpha)_2,
something like that,
was P_2.
So if it costs you a certain
amount of money,
if it costs you a quarter we
said, so this is P_2,
so through either stock,
like beta's the one I solved it
for.
I said suppose beta,
that's also equal to
pi_alpha over
D^(alpha)_2,
we said if the price of beta
turns out to be a quarter and
you're getting two dividends
then by paying a quarter you get
two dividends.
So it means to get one apple it
only costs you an eighth,
an eighth of a dollar.
So P_2 we can figure
out.
So once we've got our financial
equilibrium, it basically is
determining a general
equilibrium.
So instead so let's go
backwards.
Instead of solving for the
financial equilibrium that looks
complicated let's solve for the
general equilibrium.
What is the effective general
equilibrium?
It's the same utilities as
before, but we've augmented the
endowments.
By looking through the veil of
the stocks we realized that A
actually owns 3 apples in the
future,
1 because he owns all of stock
alpha and another one because he
owns half of stock beta.
So we've got this simple
economy that we're used to
solving that you did on the
first problem set,
so we can do it again and solve
it.
So I'm going to now solve for
general equilibrium.
I have to solve for
P_1 and P_2
and all the X^(A)_1,
X^(A)_2,
X^(B)_1,
X^(B)_2,
but I can fix one of the prices
to be one.
So I'll fix P_1 to be
1.
Then what does A do?
So I made a mistake which is
why you weren't following me.
A, his Cobb-Douglas,
2 thirds of the weight is on
good 1 and 1 third on good 2.
So he's going to spend 2 thirds
of his money on the first good.
So that's why this should have
been a 2 thirds as she pointed
out, thank you.
So 2 thirds of his money,
what's his money?
His endowment is (1,3),
so it's [(P_1 times
1), which is 1 times 1,
(3 times P_2)]
divided by the price
P_1.
2 thirds of the income divided
by the price of the first good,
that's how many of the first
good he wants to eat.
What does she want to do?
She's patient.
She's going to spend half her
income on both goods,
so half of her income which is
[(1 P_2 times 1)
divided by 1],
that's how many apples today
she wants and that's what we
have to clear to clear the apple
market at time 1.
So does this make sense now?
I'm looking at you in the front.
Do you agree with this or is
this confusing now?
Do you follow this or is this
confusing?
I can say it again if it's
confusing.
Student: I've got a
question.
Prof: Yeah?
Student: Our denominator
represents what they want to
have in the future?
Prof: Remember how the
Cobb-Douglas worked?
This trick I'm going to use
over and over again.
With log utilities everybody
will spend depending on the
coefficient.
So remember,
this utility in the problem
set, you know that this utility
is just the same as if I put 2
thirds here and 1 third here,
right?
Because I'm just dividing this
by 3, so instead of 1 and a
half--so the original utility is
this, right?
It's (log X_1) (1
half log X_2),
so the sum of this plus this is
3 halves.
I can multiply by 2 thirds.
So if I multiply this by 2
thirds I get 2 thirds here and 1
third here, right?
And I haven't changed the
utility function.
And now I know this is a
familiar pattern.
A is always going to spend 2
thirds of his money on the first
good.
And B I can multiple this whole
utility by a half and a half and
B is going spend--
and now we recognize it as the
common Cobb-Douglas thing and we
could say that A's [correction:
B's]
going to spend half his money
on the first good and half his
money on the second good.
So what have I done?
Fisher said look,
this model is so complicated.
You're thinking in your heads,
people are deciding in period 1
how much stock should I buy,
how many bonds should I buy,
how many apples should I eat,
but really if they're smart
they're not going to think that
way.
They're going to say to
themselves how many apples
should I buy today?
How many apples do I want to
consume tomorrow?
All these financial assets are
just methods for me getting
apples tomorrow in exchange for
apples today.
And what's the tradeoff between
the apples was
this--P_1 and
P_2 is the tradeoff
between apples.
You can look through the stocks
and all that,
but no matter which stock you
think of buying there's going to
be the same tradeoff between
apples today and apples tomorrow
because of the no arbitrage.
The price of alpha is going to
have to be exactly half the
price of beta.
So once I solve for this
economy and get the price of
alpha I'll know how many apples
today I have to tradeoff in
order to get apples tomorrow.
So I might as well forget about
all the stocks and just try to
figure out what must that
tradeoff between P_1
and P_2 be.
So that's why you can forget
about the stocks,
forget about the bonds,
everybody's thinking I'm
trading off apples today for
apples next year.
I'm making all the trades
today, because I'm trading
apples today in exchange for
promises for apples next period.
So it's as if everything
happens today.
It's as if they're present
value prices today.
We trade today at prices
P_1 and P_2
for apples today and apples next
year.
Of course the apples won't
appear until next year,
but I can sell an apple today
at price P_1 and buy
promises for apple next year at
a price P_2,
and that's the tradeoff I'm
facing.
If I face that tradeoff how
much of my money am I going to
spend on apples today?
I'm going to spend 2 thirds of
my money on apples today and the
other third I'll spend on
promises for apples next period.
So this is a big insight Fisher
had.
It's not surprising it's a
little puzzling.
I'm so used to it that I've
forgotten how puzzling it is.
So ask me some more questions.
This was not an obvious thought
Fisher had.
Yeah?
Student: Do we typically
expect the price in the 2nd
period to be lower than the
price in the 1st period?
Prof: Often there'll be
inflation,
so q_2--the
contemporaneous price next
period might be higher than the
contemporaneous price this
period,
but we don't care about that.
What we care about is how many
apples you have to give up today
in order to get apples tomorrow.
So P_2 is the present
value price.
What do you have to give up
today to get the apple next
period?
So we expect P_2 to
be less than P_1.
Precisely because,
well, we're going to come to
that,
that's the next thing I was
going to talk about because
everybody's putting more weight
on consumption today than they
are on consumption in the
future.
That's why the price
P_1 is going to be
bigger than the price
P_2.
Yep?
Student: When we're
solving it we're solving in real
prices?
Prof: So we're solving
for P_1 and
P_2 in present value
prices.
So the crucial thing is,
he invented this term present
value prices:
the prices you pay today no
matter when you're going to get
the stuff.
That's his big insight.
You should look at present
value prices.
Holding stocks and all that
complicated stuff is just giving
you goods in the future.
So when you buy the stocks
today you should think,
how much am I having to pay
today to get an apple in the
future?
You can deduce that from the
price of stocks and how many
dividends they're paying.
So everybody must have figured
out a P_2.
What does it cost today?
How much money do I have to
give up today to get an apple in
the future?
Well, I have to buy a stock and
then sell the dividends and all
that,
but really what I should be
thinking about is what's the
price today I'm paying for one
apple in the future,
and that's P_2.
And so when you think about it
that way,
although it's an intertemporal
problem,
it looks like a new model with
time,
Fisher said you can reduce it,
think of it as if they're just
the same problem we did before
with two goods you're trading at
the same time.
That's not an obvious thing to
have thought of.
No one thought of it before him.
Yeah?
Student: The budget set,
the second equation from the
right-hand side.
The second item shouldn't you
have a q_2 as well,
q_2 times
>?
Prof: Oh, absolutely.
So this should have been a
q_2 here because you'd
sell the dividend and you get
money by selling the dividend.
Thank you.
Ho, ho, ho, very good.
Who said that?
Who just asked that question?
Where are you?
I'll remember you.
That was very good, exactly.
So in the future you're getting
the money.
So what he pointed out is I
made another mistake here.
In the future the money you're
spending on goods in the future
you're going to get the
dividends paid,
of course you can sell the
dividends for money and the
price is q_2.
So a q_2 has to
appear over here just like
there's a q_2 over
there.
So it's the goods times the
price.
That's the money you're getting
in the future,
and that's the money you're
spending on the good
X_2.
Very good, too bad you didn't
ask me that a while ago,
but anyway.
Any other questions?
So we're back to this standard
general equilibrium problem.
We can take a financial
equilibrium and turn it into a
general equilibrium.
And so when we solve this we're
going to have (2 thirds
P_2 1 half 1 half
P_2) = 2.
So it looks like 3 halves (I
hope I haven't done this wrong)
P_2 = 2 thirds
2P_2.
Student:
>
Prof: Thank you,
yeah, plus 2P_2.
So we have 2P_2 a
half a half P_2 so we
have 5 halves P_2.
That was lucky you caught that,
5 halves P_2.
So 2 thirds is 4 sixths.
And 3 sixths is 9 sixths.
And 12 sixths - 9 sixths is...
What is this?
So what's 2 - 2 thirds - a half?
Student: 5 sixths.
Prof: 5 sixths.
That's correct.
So P_2 therefore
equals 1 third.
All right, so we've now solved
for equilibrium.
We know that P_1 has
got to be 1.
P_2 has got to be 1
third.
We know that we can figure out
what consumption's going to be,
I mean X^(A)_1,
for example,
if we wanted to solve for that
we just plug in a third here.
So we'd have (2 thirds) times
(1 3), which is 2 thirds times a
4, which is 8 thirds,
I guess.
And X^(B)_1,
we could have solved for that
too if we wanted to.
X^(B)_1 is going to
be a half times 4 thirds which
is 2 thirds.
No, that doesn't--a half plus
what was this 1 third?
No, it's 1 1 third which is 4
thirds times a half which is 2
thirds.
Is that right?
That doesn't look right,
so maybe I did this wrong.
1 1 is 2 so this is 4 thirds.
That looks better.
X^(A)_1 is 4 thirds.
X^(B)_1 is 2 thirds.
So we have 4 thirds and 2
thirds, and so we could solve
similarly for X^(A)_2
and X^(B)_2,
which I won't bother to do.
So we can figure out what the
prices are, the present value
prices and the present value
consumption.
But having done that,
Fisher says,
we took a hard problem we make
it easy.
Let's go back to the hard
problem.
So Fisher says the tradeoff
between good 1 and good 2 is 1
to a third, so he
defined--here's the nominal rate
of interest.
Fisher defined something called
the real rate of interest.
And he said that was a variable
that you should pay a lot of
attention to.
So the real rate of interest he
said is P_1 divided by
P_2,
so this is equal to 3 and so r
is 200 percent.
So how did I get that?
Just as someone in the front
said the good 2 is much less
expensive.
The present value of good 2 is
much less than the present value
of good 1.
People think an apple today is
much more valuable than an apple
tomorrow.
So if you give up an apple
today you can get 3 apples next
year.
So if you put an apple in the
bank it's like getting 200
percent interest on apples.
So he called that the real
rate--the apple rate of
interest.
You put an apple in the bank,
you give up an apple today,
buy stocks and when it comes
out in the end you've got 200
percent more apples than you
started with.
So it's the real rate of
interest.
So that's his crucial variable.
Now, let's go back to the
original equilibrium.
What is the stock price?
Assume q_1 = 1.
What is the stock price
pi_alpha?
Well, we can figure it out.
How can we figure it out?
What is pi_alpha?
Well, stock alpha pays 1 good
tomorrow so what is the price of
pi_alpha?
Student:
>
Prof: What?
Somebody said it.
I couldn't hear it--a third.
How did I get a third?
Because we figured out that
once everybody looks through the
veil,
assuming the price
P_1 is 1 and the price
q_1 is 1,
if they look through the veil
they're going to say to
themselves ah-ha,
how much do I have to pay today
to get an apple in the future?
I have to pay a third to get
one apple in the future.
P_1 is 3 times
P_2.
So to get 1 apple in the
future, it's only a third of an
apple today.
So the stock pays 1 apple in
the future so therefore how much
do I have to pay today?
I have to pay 1 third of an
apple today, and since I took
the price of apples to be 1 it's
going to be the price of 1
third.
So what's the price beta?
Student: 2 thirds.
Prof: 2 thirds.
So Fisher said look,
we've solved now for all these
financial things.
So what you can't do,
Fisher's theory does not
explain how much of each stock,
theta^(A), etcetera,
the investors hold.
Why is that?
Well, because it doesn't matter.
Not enough is happening in the
economy yet.
Alpha and beta are exactly the
same.
If you own twice as much of the
alpha tree you get exactly the
same as having the beta tree.
So how can you possibly tell
whether somebody's going to hold
twice the alpha tree or just one
beta tree?
Either way he's going to get
the same thing.
So the theory can't possibly
explain which one they're going
to do.
Somehow they'll work it out and
divide up the tree so that
everybody ends up with the right
number of apples in the end.
And it also does not explain
inflation because you can't tell
what q_2 is going to
be.
All right, because you see in
this budget set,
thanks to that inspired
question, if you double
q_2,
q_2 appears
everywhere;
you're not going to change the
second equation.
So q_2 could be
anything.
You can double it or triple it,
it won't matter,
and the same with
q_1.
It's just like Walras said
before, you can always normalize
prices to be one.
He had to add another theory of
money and how many dollars were
floating around in the economy
to explain q_2.
This theory won't explain it.
So it does not explain
inflation, and it does not
explain who holds which stock,
and so it does not explain the
nominal rate of interest.
It does not explain i,
the nominal rate of interest,
because 1 dollar,
who knows what 1 dollar's going
to be worth.
It depends on how much
inflation we have.
But it does explain the real
rate of interest.
It does explain r,
and that's the variable that
Fisher said is the one
economists should always pay
attention to,
the real rate of interest.
So that's the crucial variable.
So if you want to figure out
what's the price today of a
stock,
so Fisher's famous equation's
the price of the stock today,
so pi_alpha divided
by q_1,
so the real price,
as somebody said,
the price in terms of goods of
the stock today is always going
to equal the dividend in the
future divided by 1 r.
Why is that?
That's exactly what we already
used.
This is just a rewriting of the
trick we did before.
You take the dividend tomorrow,
you multiply it by
P_2 and then you
realize that 1 r is just
P_1 divided by
P_2,
so replacing the P_1s
and P_2s by
q_1 and 1 r,
today's real stock price is
just the dividends tomorrow
discounted.
This is what he called the
Fundamental Theorem of Asset
Pricing.
If you knew the real rate of
interest you'd be able to figure
out what all the stocks were
worth just like we did.
Once we knew P_1 and
P_2,
the present value--the present
value prices determine the
interest rate because they're--
just as we said.
P_1 over
P_2,
remember, is 1 r.
So knowing P_1 and
P_2 you're always
normalizing P_1 to be
1, P_2's the same as 1
over 1 r.
So if you know P_2 or
you know 1 over 1 r,
you know what the value of the
stocks are.
That's his critical insight.
Now, just to finish...
Yes?
Student: That's
q_2 or q_1?
Prof: q_1,
q_1 which is the same
as P_1 because it's
today's price.
The contemporaneous price today
is the present value of the
price today.
So let me just end on this one
note.
Fisher said we can take
financial equilibrium without
uncertainty, reduce it to
general equilibrium.
We know everything about
general equilibrium,
therefore we know everything
about financial equilibrium,
and we realize that the crucial
variable in general equilibrium
is relative prices.
There is no just interest rate.
The nominal interest rate,
who the hell cares?
The real interest rate is what
we care about,
and just in normal economics
there's no just relative price,
there's no just real interest
rate.
It depends on people's
utilities.
You make them more patient and
that's going to affect the real
interest rate.
You make them less patient it's
going to affect the real
interest rate.
You give them more endowments
today versus tomorrow,
that's going to affect the real
interest rate.
The relative price between
today and tomorrow--that's the
way you should think about
finance.
That's the way you should
explain what's going on in the
financial markets.
So in the problem set you're
just going to do a problem like
that, and then I'm going to give
more interpretations of this
that Fisher gave.
So I guess I'm out of time,
so we'll stop here.